how do I compare these pizza with the
one they are all over eating well where
do you were the start how to tea my name
is Simona Falco I'm the chef/owner of
Rosso Pomodoro I've been making pizza
since I was very young I'm very excited
today because you're gonna discover
which one is the best delivery pizza you
can get home stay tuned
[Music]
let's see what we have here feels
supersoft and a little oily or the
flower and the name s bar that's why the
color is so dark a lot of these may be
potatoes there's a gooey line right in
the middle looks pretty good sweet is
the first things that comes in tomato
sauce
not bad is a sauce on the side there's a
lot of butter
ah it's a garlic all of these may be
deeper in there
oh it's having a pizza with mayonnaise
and maybe some people like I don't
really enjoy it I guess it's a good
start Wow we are with the pepperoni no
bad the underneath part is to cook much
better they might use oil or butter make
a crispy the smell is more of a cake
calzone more than a pizza the crust is
stuffed with not just cheese my
mozzarella bring the cheese of a better
quality in less sugar less Dori things a
little too soft nor enough to me this
overly a little overall is not bad pull
out directly from the fridge here abide
before you go to bed I won't do that
[Music]
okay definitely thinner grass I can see
oregano the crowd smells of oil instead
easily door tight it's pretty good I
don't see sugar in the tomato sauce
which makes me very happy
I don't taste the sugar into the dogs
makes me happy again it stays there as
entry' pores is the pizza I would like
to sit on the couch on a Sunday watching
the football with an easy build or as I
prefer the wine
it delivers things is the best so far is
my favorite holiday oh my lord this is
nice what is it it's a pie I see a lot
of cottages mushrooms jalapeno uncooked
dough dance don't we but the cooking
technique is much better they use very
good ingredient the heavy weight on top
these girls but that part feels to me
like soupy
and here we are seniority a seniority we
use a little semolina flour to make a
crispier which will give a nice by the
nice touch the cooking technique is good
holds up well a lot a lot a lot of olive
oil in the dough
sweet sugar back the amount of sugar
that you feel everywhere for me too much
so overall I guess early balance
definitely on the top rank on the one
that we tried today the culture of pizza
is the neighbor plays the family that
runs if you talk with them I like
something more simple and either hot
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]